probably a difficult start for you that
lasts with the white pieces against
Chicago but bounced back immediately
with two back-to-back victories
especially this one this was not easy it
looked almost unusable for Gary at some
point in the end game yet you managed to
trick him tell us a bit about this yeah
two very clean games against rain again
very smooth
from start to finish I played no I just
lost upon the opening I was dead lost
against Gary I was also probably losing
against prey at least uh much worse yes
that wasn't I mean okay I don't know if
I was dead lost against Gary but it was
it was pretty bad once he won the pawn
and I'm just a pawn down for nothing he
also has a good structure oh
My Hope was that he's low on time and
that's more or less why I managed to
escape and um but I have to say he
accurately took the game to the end game
you know simplified the position and you
guys got to this
uh position right now E5 yeah I was at
least happy I got this E5 I mean he has
10 seconds at this moment I I was more
worried at some moment that he would
play E5 himself maybe in the middle game
and then I get a fixed weakness on e4
so yeah 9c6 E4 actually spent a bit of
time calculating Rook 8. it was kind of
it's kind of a fun move
um yeah the thing is if
yeah like um
yeah Knight of six that's why I rejected
this finally I didn't see anything here
but the main point is that Knight of
Faith there is this trick F5 it's if
it's sort of King G7 Knight f8
19 sorry sorry instead of King G7 Knight
f8 if he follows that got it then that
five it's uh at least in time trouble
it's very easy to get amazing yeah
and then if 97 97 that's a problem he
drops The Rook uh but okay I I actually
I didn't see this I just thought Rook C7
but this is even nicer this is very nice
so nice
so I had to avoid Temptation there
instead I went for yeah Knight of six
years very good but he was low on time
and 906 Bishop three it's still still a
mess
94. it's not like he's completely
winning and
in time trouble Anything Can Happen
still you still have two Bishops yeah
yeah then it was a safe position for him
I mean he's
he's definitely not worse he's a bit
better
but uh
but yeah I guess it's objectively a draw
and then
he made this terrible King D I mean
something like
okay I guess it's not so terrible
objectively but from practical point of
view he he starts to lose his pawns upon
yeah he can he can make a move like
Bishop five I guess yeah Rook A2 yeah
before that's that's what I was thinking
about five here is a decent move most
natural way to continue and then okay he
loses his D6 Pawn so he has to
um now now I don't risk at all
and then I I almost flagged myself for
some moment I had like once I didn't
realize I was kind of focused on the
position I think perhaps it was uh this
point when you played Rook A7
yeah I don't know why I suddenly started
to get confused because Knight's jumping
around and
um and I realized that I could easily
lose both my pawns but then I
just made a random Rook move and figured
I'll probably have a meeting at some
some moments anyway yep which yeah
and I don't think he let it go at any
point yeah this one was precise it would
be six hours a week I guess it's the
same thing but yeah this the problem is
he's he's both getting mated and his
Knight is in a bad position so
so yeah he loses here but uh okay very
very fortunate and today Bobby at one
point still behind the leaders sorry
feeling about your chances going into
the last three
yeah I'll just have to have a very big
final day if I want to fight for first
place so that's pretty clear and I do
play both of them so that gives me some
hope live on and Saturday yeah live on
and Sam I I'm not sure which order but
uh my last three will be live on Sam and
Jeffrey and I guess they're all I think
Jeffrey is also doing decently so it's
not going to be an easy final day but I
didn't think any day would be easy I
mean everyone is very capable here
everyone's very strong guys any
questions no just tired congratulations
Fabi for a nice win over Gary there I
think he just out played them very
nicely in the end game